because I only have so few minutes with
you I want to start with um I'll avoid
that and just say congratulations on the
sequel uh you did it again uh really fun
movie
um uh a bunch of questions so I'm
curious was Mycroft not included because
of Sam's schedule or because you wanted
to focus more on like the Sherlock and
Nola relationship
well it was Sam's schedule that became
very clear so Sam was not going to be in
it
um that obviously a lot was we were very
sorry that Sam couldn't be in this one
he may be one if there was a future one
we would love to have him back but that
was just the the practicalities of life
that then meant though that we had to
then concentrate on Sherlock which has
some advantages in the sense and that
you it becomes a sharp pencil if you
like if you're just having to work with
that Clarity with that particular
relationship it had to be about Sherlock
Anna Nola and coming together so I guess
there is some blessings in having less
pieces because you can do more with what
you have but we love Sam we absolutely
love him and uh and we would love to
have him again the ending of the film
without getting specific sets up a lot
and I'm just curious because uh now that
you've made one sequel how much of you
guys like sort of when you were making
this how much were you sort of thinking
about what could happen in the future I
didn't think about it
I just try to tell the story as it was
because you're following your nose you
know the you can get yourself in a jam
if you try to reverse engineer you just
got to follow the nose of the character
thinking well I'm going to be heading in
this direction it feels right to me I
did want to put her and and and we want
to bring her and Sherlock together I
wanted to bring her and chicksby
together I wanted them to be involved
because of the case not because of
anything the romance is incidental to
her it's a complete a heart and head
struggle you know she thinks she's not
in love with Tewksbury she just thinks
he's of use to her and similarly you
know she doesn't know how much she is is
becoming wrapped up in Sherlock's World
they just need each other and that's why
that's the story it's the great stories
of of individuals in education plots if
you like
um we um our conscious selves lead us
into the the the truth that we're hiding
so I don't know where that's answering
your question but
um uh is it answering your question
someone else it went it went off a
little bit but it's totally okay I was
just curious uh uh man I have a lot of
other let me jump to something different
I like how this film weaves in real
history and can you sort of talk about
um uh you know bringing in real history
and Crossing it over into this world
yeah it's it was so exciting we did in
the first one with the great Reform Act
this was uh we wanted a story of
well we saw and remembered and I kind of
dusted off my memory of the match girls
Factory strike I thought well here's a
story of Sisterhood here's a story of
going from a story that was about uh
constitutional change to Social and
Union change to uh industrial action
this was meaty stuff and we were right
at the heart of it the very first strike
before by a woman for women
um it meant that uh if that was where we
were leading it up to we had to find a
mystery within it then that lost girl
could take her into a story of
Sisterhood and cooperation and that
theme that we were we were working
interested in right from the start in
the sequel was going from I to we a
story of a girl with an end just on her
own just managing to learn at the age of
15 to stand on her own two feet to
someone who has to survive in the real
world and that involves not just being
proud and individualistic and defensive
but learning to accept help and work
with others to get what you need that
tied in with the the real events of the
of the match girl strike which was uh
politically relevant and also relevant
to today it's kind of sickening and
exciting to think that that's still
going on women are still having to stand
with each other they're doing it in Iran
right now to
um stand up
as a group and they can't work without
each other and they have to stand
shoulder to shoulder and that's a level
of risk it requires Great courage it
takes courage to change and that
continued a theme that we had in the
first film that the mother and exemplary
sort of you know exemplifies so it
brought a whole it worked a whole lot of
string strings together for us that made
sense thematically on that note I gotta
stop I'm just going to say I hope it's a
huge hit and you get to make another
God bless you thank you very much